if you're a capable enough man and
you're brilliant enough then the female
has no choice but it's very interesting
this goes back into a point I made
earlier about how important it is for us
men to find women who we don't believe
have had a lot of life experience and
look like they are because I got
attacked I'm gonna make this point right
now I got attacked when the Matrix
attacked me and [ __ ] lied about me
they said that men are interested in
women who are younger because they're
more programmable and that they're
trying to make out that I'm making out
that men are out here trying to get
women and [ __ ] do bad things to them
no what I'm saying is if you find a
woman who's younger and could do less
things less trauma less relationships
less headache she's live less life your
ideals if you ask anyone who loves her
man what's your favorite song his
favorite song who do you vote for who he
votes for what's your favorite car his
car that's how it happens when a woman
loves a man and that makes the man feel
good right if she's been through too
much [ __ ] then that's a lot harder to
pull off so that that that that that
link is very important for men and women